Sean said that he heard Anthony was
writing for Fallon once and pitched a
joke regarding pinata blood and said
quote it doesn't have to be real blood
Sean said after saying that Fallon just
stared at Anthony and Anthony just
stared back and it lasted nearly five
minutes once a week they would make all
the writers come in after the show and
Pitch ideas for like segments and there
were like two instances where Jimmy
would be flat out angry at what I had
pitched but pinata full of blood was a
thing I thought would be like making fun
of the audience games we would play they
have audience members come down
blindfold them and hit a pinata that was
filled with blood
and blood would go everywhere and they'd
be horrified and Jimmy like looks almost
visibly sick and then Jimmy's like and I
go Jimmy it doesn't have to be real
blood